DAGEN McDOWELL, "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
TODAY IS APRIL FOOLS’ DAY, IF
YOU ARE LIKE ME, YOU ARE WAITING
FOR SOMEONE TO FINALLY TELL US
THIS IS ALL ONE BIG GIANT PRANK.
BUT IT’S REAL.
AND IT’S GOING TO GET MORE REAL.
WE NEED TO STAY HOME AND STAY
SANE.
WE NEED TO HOLD IT TOGETHER.
AND SO FAR WE HAVE.
CALLING THIS HEROIC IS AN
UNDERSTATEMENT.
IT’S NOT ABOUT HAVING THE
COURAGE TO STAY HOME AND DO
PUZZLES.
NO, WE ARE DRIVING OUR ECONOMY
TO THE FAR EDGE OF ITS LIMITS IN
ORDER TO SAVE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE LIVES.
MEANWHILE, CRIME IS DROPPING.
SO ARE THUGS TO STAYING ALSO?
OR MAYBE SOCIAL MEDIA WHICH WE
OFTEN BASH HAS TRANSFORMED INTO
SOMETHING CRUCIAL?
LIKE THE MY PILLOW GUY MAKING
HOSPITAL MASKS, SOCIAL MEDIA
SUDDENLY BECAME ESSENTIAL BY
ALLOWING THE SEPARATED TO JOIN.
IT’S NOW THE GLUE.
STILL, NOW HAS NEVER BEEN A
BETTER TIME TO AVOID MEDIA’S
LATEST DIVISIVE OFFERINGS.
WITH THE SHEAR STRESS OF THE
SHUTDOWN, WHO NEEDS THAT?
IT’S HARD ENOUGH.
MAYBE WE ARE SHEDDING THAT
NEGATIVITY NATURALLY.
DID YOU NOTICE HOW THE TV
SEGMENTS YOU USED TO SEE
PREQUARANTINE HAVE DISAPPEARED?
THE RACISM, SEXISM, GENDER
PRONOUNS?
WHERE’S ANTIFA POSTMARKED IT WE
STOP CANCELING PEOPLE FOREVER?
WE MAY NOT BE IMMUNE TO THE
MEDIA’S INFLUENCE, BETTER UNITY
HAS DESTROYED THE ASSESSMENT OF
WHO WE ARE.
WE ARE STICKING TOGETHER, NOT
TURNING ON EACH OTHER.
WE ARE EXACTLY WHO WE THINK WE
ARE, AND WHO THE MEDIA SAYS WE
AREN’T.
WITH 9/11, WE SENT TROOPS TO
WAR.
HERE WE ARE ALL THE TROOPS NOW.
TEAM AMERICA.
BUT UNITY DOES NOT PAY THE
BILLS.
OR CAN IT?
IT’S THE FIRST OF THE MONTH.
YOU HAVE RENTED.
MORTGAGES, UTILITIES,
CREDIT CARD INTEREST THAT WOULD
MAKE DON CORLEY ON
FLUSH.
IT IS TIME FOR A PAUSE, LIKE I
SAID IN AN AUTO SPORTS, THE
YELLOW FLAG AS ALL DRIVERS SLOW
DOWN, NOBODY PASSES, WE STAY IN
THE SAME PLACE,, AND NOBODY
OVERTAKES ANOTHER.
WE NEED THAT HERE.
EVERYONE GETS A BYE WEEK ON
THEIR BILLS.
AND THAT INCLUDES LANDLORDS.
IF THEY ARE NOT GETTING THE
RENT, TAX, MORTGAGES, THEY GET A
BYE WEEK TOO.
BUT NOTHING GOES OUT AND NOTHING
COMES IN.
IT IS A FREEZE.
IMAGINE THE ECONOMY LIKE A
REMOTE, AND YOU HIT PAUSE ON
THAT TV CALLED LIFE.
IN A MONTH, WE COULD HIT PLAY
AND DOUBLE THE SPEED TO CATCH
YOU, BUT FOR NOW CONSIDER IT A
PASS AMONG FELLOW CITIZENS.
THAT WAY WHEN YOUR GRANDKIDS ASK
YOU WHAT YOU DID IN THE GREAT
QUARANTINE OF 2020, YOU CAN SAY,
NOT MUCH.
BUT THE WEIRDEST THING IS WE DID
IT ALTOGETHER.
DANA, I HAVE A THEORY.
>> Dana: YES.
I LOVE YOUR THEORIES.
>> Greg: OH, THANK YOU.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN THIS MASS
COOPERATION ON SUCH A HUGE
SCALE.
AND I’M BEGINNING TO THINK IT IS
MY FAULT.
THAT I WAS SOMEHOW TRICKED BEING
IN A MEDIA BUBBLE TO THINK THAT
WE ALL HATE EACH OTHER, THAT IT
IS MEN VERSUS WOMEN, BLACK
VERSUS WHITE, GAYS VERSUS
STRAIGHT, AND THE AMERICAN UNITY
WAS LOST.
WE ARE ALL POCKETS OF IDENTITY,
BUT IT SEEMS THAT THAT THEORY
HAS BEEN BLOWN OUT OF THE WATER,
FOR NOW ANYWAY.
>> Dana: THANKFULLY SO, RIGHT?
BECAUSE WHAT YOU ARE SEEING IS
THE TRUE SPIRIT OF AMERICA.
AND IT IS UNFORTUNATE THAT
SOMETIMES IT TAKES A CRISIS TO
BE REMINDED OF THAT.
BUT I LOVED WHAT YOU SAID AT THE
END.
WE ARE NOT DOING ANYTHING, BUT
WE ARE DOING IT ALTOGETHER.
THERE IS A LOT TO DO.
ON MY SHOW TODAY, THERE WAS -- I
HAD A REPORT FROM MOLLY LINE,
AND SHE LOOKED ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AT FOOD BANKS, FOR
EXAMPLE.
AND IT WAS REALLY QUITE
OVERWHELMING TO ME.
AND YOU REALIZE WHAT THE
GOVERNMENT IS ASKING US TO DO IS
AN ENORMOUS RESPONSIBILITY THAT
THE PRESIDENT HAS TWO-WAY THE
INFORMATION HE IS GETTING FROM
THE HEALTH EXPERTS, BUT ALSO BE
MINDFUL THAT THERE IS AN ENTIRE
COUNTRY AND THE WELL-BEING OF
THE ECONOMY, AND NOT DOING TOO
MUCH HARM THEY ARE.
AND IT IS A DIFFICULT BALANCE.
AND IT IS PRETTY WONDERFUL SO
FAR TO SEE PEOPLE DOING THEIR
PART, AND HELPING THOSE PEOPLE
WHO ARE ON THE FRONT LINES.
THE TROOPS THAT ARE ON THE FRONT
LINES IN THE HOSPITALS.
AND I LIKE BEING PULLED
TOGETHER.
IT FEELS GOOD.
>> Greg: DAGAN, I HOPE THAT
YOU NOTICE THAT I AM DRESSED
ALIKE DUG DOG IN A NIGHT AT THE
ROCKS VERY JUST FOR YOU.
MY THEORY ON THE PAUSE WHERE
NOTHING GOES IN AND NOTHING GOES
OUT, DOESN’T THAT MAKE SENSE
THAT IF EVERYBODY IS FROZEN AND
THEY DON’T HAVE TO PAY FOR
ANYTHING, NOBODY FALLS BEHIND
AND NOBODY LOSES ANYTHING.
ISHIS JUST A FANTASY IN MY
BRAIN THAT DOESN’T WORK?
>> Dagen: NO, IT IS NOT A
FANTASY.
BUT ONE OF THE --
>> Dana: DON’T GO THERE,
DAGAN.
>> Dagen: I ALWAYS GO WONKY,
BUT ONE OF THE REASONS THAT THE
FEDERAL RESERVE IS THEY ARE
BECAUSE YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE CREDITORS ARE NOT
INSOLVENT.
YOU NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO ARE OWED MONEY DON’T
GO FROM HAVING LIQUIDITY
PROBLEMS TO COMPLETE INSOLVENCY.
BECAUSE WE WANT THOSE JOBS TO BE
THERE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF ALL
OF THIS.
BUT THERE WILL BE A PAUSE.
I AM WORRIED ABOUT THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED.
TOMORROW WE WILL GET THE WEEKLY
JOB CLAIMS NUMBERS AT 8:30 A.M.
WE HAD A RECORD NUMBER THE
PREVIOUS WEEK.
IT WAS A MOSTLY .3 MILLION
PEOPLE HIRING FOR UNEMPLOYMENT.
TOMORROW IT COULD BE
5.5 MILLION.
AND THE UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS,
THE OFFICE AND ALMOST EVERY
STATE ARE COMPLETELY SLAMMED AND
JAMMED.
PEOPLE CANNOT EVEN SIGN UP.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING EXTRA
MONEY, THE ALLOCATED $600 PER
MONTH YET, AND THE
SELF-EMPLOYED, THEY ARE HAVING
TROUBLE, BECAUSE THE STATE
STONING KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE NOW FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
BENEFITS.
SO AT THE END OF THAT I LOOK AT
THEM AS INDIVIDUALS.
THESE ARE NOT NUMBERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO HAVE LOST
THEIR JOBS OVERNIGHT.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING TO PAY THEIR
BILLS AND PUT FOOD ON THE TABLE.
AND THERE ARE FAMILIES THAT ARE
SUFFERING.
NOT JUST FROM THE VIRUS, BUT THE
FINANCIAL CRISIS.
AND WE HAVE TO THINK ABOUT IT
LIKE THAT.
BEFORE BETWEEN ONE, I READ THAT
60% OF THE WORKERS WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS
IN UNDER A WEEK FROM NOW.
HOW CAN WE SIMPLIFY THIS
PROCESS?
SO THAT WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO
APPLY FOR THINGS, IF THEY HAVE A
SMALL BUSINESS, YOU HAVE TO GO
THROUGH SO MUCH RED TAPE TO GET
THE MONEY THAT YOU NEED?
ISN’T THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
CUT THROUGH THIS LIKE WE DID
OTHER THINGS?
>> Juan: I DON’T KNOW.
OBVIOUSLY THAT’S WHY WE PASSED
THAT HUGE, WHAT SOME PEOPLE WANT
TO CALL A STIMULUS.
I THINK OF IT AS A BAND-AID,
GREG.
IT WILL HELP PEOPLE.
YOU WILL SEE THE MONEY COMING
INTO AMERICAN POCKETS WITHIN A
WEEK OR SO.
AND FOR SMALL BUSINESSES, THEY
HAVE THE ABILITY TO NOT ONLY GET
LOANS, BUT IN SOME CASES GRANTS.
I THINK THAT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
BUT I THINK A LOT OF THE TONE IS
SET BY THE PRESIDENT IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
AND YESTERDAY, BOY, I THINK
JUDGING BY HIS WORDS, WHAT HAS
GONE ON HAS REALLY SUNK IN FOR
THE PRESIDENT.
THAT HELPS TO BRING US TOGETHER
TO HAVE THAT LEADERSHIP.
I THINK IT IS HARD FOR ANYBODY
TO GRASP WHEN YOU SEE THOSE
GRAPHS THAT WERE PUT UP BY
DR. FAUCI, DR. BIRX.
AND THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT
100,000 DEATHS.
THAT IS THE BEST-CASE SCENARIO.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT CAN
REALLY SHOCK YOU.
AND I THINK WITH ALL OF US, I
DON’T CARE WHAT POCKET OF
AMERICA YOU ARE IN, THIS IS A
CHALLENGE FOR US AS A NATION AND
A PEOPLE TO COME TO GRIPS WITH
IT.
SO I THINK THAT NOW YOU ARE
SEEING SOME OF THE GOVERNORS,
WHO HAVE BEEN SLOW TO SAY, HEY,
STAY AT HOME.
THEY ARE STARTING TO SAY IT.
I THINK WHAT YOU ARE STARTING TO
SEE YOU NOW, FINALLY,
UNDERSTANDING THAT THIS IS NOT
THE FLU.
SOME PEOPLE WERE DOWNPLAYING.
THIS IS NOT THE FLU.
IT IS SO MUCH MORE SERIOUS AND
HAS SO MUCH MORE GRAVITY IN
TERMS OF POTENTIAL FATALITIES,
THAT YOU ARE TALKING ABOUT.
SO MANY DEATHS.
>> Greg: JESSE, WHAT ARE YOUR
THOUGHTS?
>> Jesse: WE ARE ABOUT TO HIT
THE DARKEST DAYS.
AND AMERICANS ARE COMING
TOGETHER.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
TRYING TO DIMINISH OUR SPIRITS.
SO LET’S LOOK BACK AT THE LAST
75 DAYS, JUST TWO AND A HALF
MONTHS OF HOW THIS THING STARTED
JUST IN MID-JANUARY, THE WORLD
HEALTH ORGANIZATION SAID THAT
THE VIRUS WAS NOT CONTAGIOUS.
PEOPLE DO PEOPLE TRANSFER WAS
IMPOSSIBLE.
AND EVEN THEN THE PRESIDENT
SLAPPED THE TRAVEL BAN ON CHINA.
AND FORM THE TASK FORCE, AND
SAID TO THE CHINESE, LET’S SEND
OUR SCIENTIST TO WUHAN TO
INVESTIGATE, AND CHINA SAID, NO.
AND THEN HE ACTUALLY MENTIONED
THE VIRUS AT THE STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
THE ADDRESS THAT NANCY RIPPED UP
AFTERWARDS.
WE HAVE GONE IN JUST A MATTER OF
WEEKS FROM A PREVENTION STRATEGY
TO A MITIGATION STRATEGY.
REMEMBER, JANUARY AND FEBRUARY
WAS ALL ABOUT THE TRAVEL BAN,
THE QUARANTINE, AND $8 BILLION.
MARCH WAS A FULL-SCALE SHUTDOWN
AND ASKING FOR $2 TRILLION.
DR. FAUCI SAID WE GOT THIS THING
AHEAD OF IT VERY EARLY.
AND DR. BIRX SAID, EVERYBODY
THOUGHT THAT THIS WAS A SARS
LIKE VIRUS COMING OUT OF CHINA.
BUT THE CHINESE LIGHT AND THAT’S
WHAT CAUGHT OFFICE OFF GUARD.
A MONTH AGO, YOU DO YOU KNOW HOW
MANY DEATHS THERE WERE IN THE
UNITED STATES FROM THIS VIRUS?
ONE.
IN THREE WEEKS AGO WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT THE SOUTH CAROLINA
PRIMARY.
JOE BIDEN AND MAYOR PETE WAS
GOING TO DROP OUT.
THAT’S HOW LONG AGO THAT WAS.
AND IT FEELS LIKE THAT IN OUR
HEAD.
NOT TOO LONG AGO, GOVERNOR CUOMO
WAS SAYING GO EAT OUT IN
NEW YORK CITY.
GOVERNOR DeFAZIO HAD ALL OF
THE SCHOOLS OPEN.
NANCY SAID BRING YOUR FRIENDS TO
CHINATOWN AND GO TO THE BARS.
EVERY COLUMN IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES,"
"THE WASHINGTON POST,"
DOWNPLAYING THIS THING.
AND ACTUALLY, MORNING JOE HAD
THE AUDACITY, THE OTHER DAY TO
SAY THAT EVERYBODY SAW THIS
COMING IN JANUARY.
DO YOU KNOW HOW MANY SEGMENTS
MORNING JOE DID ON THE VIRUS IN
JANUARY?
ONE.
A GUY WHO SAID DON’T WORRY ABOUT
THIS VIRUS, WORRY ABOUT THE FLU.
FINALLY, EVERYONE IS ON BOARD.
YOUNG PEOPLE, OLD PEOPLE, LEFT,
RIGHT.
WE ARE ALL IN THIS TOGETHER NOW.
AND WE NEED TO STAY TOGETHER
UNTIL WE BEAT IT.